[Musik]
besucher ansturm an deutschlands küsten
die ersten ostsee badeorte machen wegen
überfüllung dicht facebook lenkt ein
nachdem sich werbekunden zurückzogen
kündigt das unternehmen an mehr gegen
hass im internet zu tun
aufatmen in bremen mit einem klaren sieg
gegen köln sichert sich werder den
relegationsplatz
fortuna düsseldorf steigt ab
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den nachrichten am samstag norbert
lehmann ist auch dabei heute mit äußeren
sportlich haben doch von mir
es ist eine menge los auf den straßen in
deutschland entdeckt zu ferienbeginn
heute gerade seine urlaubsregion wieder
schon musste der eine oder andere
badeort an der see wegen überfüllung
schließen eingeschränkt bleiben nur die
bewohner aus sogenannten corona hotspots
bund und länder haben sich aber darauf
geeinigt dass auch die reisen und
beherbergt werden dürfen wenn sie
negativ getestet wurden
wie die familie aus gütersloh die lothar
becker getroffen hat familie würde man
erste station ihrer urlaubsreise führt
heute zum corona drive-in test in
gütersloh
binnen 24 stunden sollen die ergebnisse
dann vorliegen
wir fahren jetzt erst nach urlaubsreisen
auch in nordrhein westfalen
da dürfen wir auch ohne test noch drauf
mussten auch ein fragebogen ausfüllen
das war halt nicht im kontakt hatten den
letzten 14 tagen mit einem google 19
infizierten und wartet man da den test
ab und fahren dann weiter nach kappeln
und dann eventuell weiter nach dänemark
nrw gesundheitsminister karl josef
laumann dank bei einem besuch den
einsatzkräften von bundeswehr thw und
rettungsdiensten die aktuelle
zwischenbilanz der massentests zeigt
dass 8400 menschen mittlerweile getestet
worden sind immer mal bezahlen und wir
4140 testergebnisse haben 4250 sind noch
nicht untersucht oder die untersuchungen
liegen noch nicht vor aber man hat war
diese vielen menschen nur neun menschen
gefunden die positiv sind alle anderen
können mit gültigem testergebnis in den
urlaub starten an nord und ostsee wird
es jedoch schneller voll als sonst und
schutz und eine nasen schutz ist nicht
notwendig aber man soll sich regelmäßig
die hände waschen und
der gebotene abstand von 15 metern ist
natürlich einzuhalten
in scharbeutz an der ostsee wurden daher
zugänge zu stränden geschlossen und der
verkehr umgeleitet bei bestem wetter war
der andrang von tages und feriengästen
zeitweise schlicht zu groß nach lokalen
corona ausbrüchen den gütersloh hat sich
die zahl der neuinfektionen in
deutschland erhöht hier die aktuellen
zahlen im durchschnitt der vergangenen
sieben tage steckten sich täglich 530
menschen neu mit dem virus an
gestern waren es 500 10 wer darf wohin
reisen die eu diskutiert gerade was
künftig für bürger aus ländern außerhalb
der union gilt der aktuelle ein
reisestopp läuft ende juni aus und jetzt
ist offenbar eine einigung in sicht
wichtigstes kriterium soll die zahl der
chor ohne neue infektionen sein wenn ein
staat ungefähr auf eu-niveau oder besser
liegt dürfen seine bürger einreißen
außerdem will sich die eu anschauen wie
konsequent das land mit der korona krise
umgeht damit scheint so viel schon
einmal klar die eu grenzen bleiben für
bürger etwa aus den usa aus brasilien
und russland wahrscheinlich dicht die
müssen also vorläufig wohl
draußenbleiben stefan leifert in brüssel
lassen sie sich das einreiseverbot ohne
weiteres gefallen diesen ländern wird
nichts anderes übrig bleiben aber
natürlich ist hier in brüssel und den eu
hauptstädten jedem klar
die politisch aufgeladen diese
entscheidung ist deswegen hat man sie
sich auch nicht leicht gemacht im falle
der usa wird man wohl den preis bezahlen
dass es weitere politische spannungen
gibt und auch wohl den preis bezahlen
das eu bürgern ihrerseits die einreise
in die usa erst mal weiterhin verwehrt
bleibt das heißt eine urlaubssaison
zwischen eu und usa wird es bis auf
weiteres nicht geben
seit tagen ring die eu-staaten in
videokonferenzen und physischen präsenz
konferenzen immer wieder um eine liste
mit namen mit länder nahmen und mit
kriterien die dann ab dem 17 gelten
sollen und die interessenunterschiede
innerhalb der eu-staaten die sind
gewaltig es gibt eine fraktion von
nordländern vor allem die für einen sehr
rigiden
einreise kurs plädiert haben auf der
anderen seite viele südländer die sehr
vom tourismus abhängig sind wie portugal
oder griechenland die er für ein
öffnungskurs plädiert haben diese
interessen unterschiede auszugleichen
ist jetzt das ziel bis montag bis dahin
soll die liste endgültig stehen
im moment reden wir ungefähr über 15 bis
20 länder für die wieder geöffnet werden
soll darunter südkorea australien oder
neuseeland also durchgesetzt hat sich
eher die rigide fraktion die eu bleibt
also corona bedingt erst mal bis auf
weiteres auf abschottung schools danke
für die aufklärung stefan leifert aus
brüssel
corona ist teuer für das
gesundheitssystem tests behandlungen
medikamente kosten milliarden für arme
länder ist das kaum zu schaffen
deshalb hat die eu gemeinsam mit einer
hilfsorganisation eine virtuelle
geberkonferenz organisiert dabei kamen
mehr als sechs milliarden euro zusammen
ein ziel ist es das künftige impfstoffe
für alle weltweit zur verfügung stehen
schon lange steht facebook in der kritik
weil der konzern zu wenig gegen fake
news und hass botschaften unternimmt
jetzt hat firmengründer zuckerberg
angekündigt posts die diskriminieren
oder zu gewalt aufrufen von der
plattform zu entfernen
ein grund könnte der boykott von
wichtigen werbekunden seien
dazu gehört der unilever konzern mit
marken wie langnese pfanni oder koralle
waschmittel auch der autobauer honda
will keine werbung mehr auf facebook
schalten und coca cola zieht als zeichen
gegen rassismus inzwischen nach an
seinem stern
hass hetze und lügen im netz weit
verbreitet auch bei facebook
der chef mark zuckerberg steht deshalb
gewaltig unter druck und verspricht
jetzt aufrufe zu gewalt zu löschen und
falschmeldungen klar zu kennzeichnen
es gibt keine ausnahme bei inhalten die
etwa gewalt fördern oder das wahlrecht
unterdrücken auch nicht wenn sie von
politikern kommen politikern wie donald
trump der bereits ordentlich ärger hat
mit twitter trump behauptete hier
briefwahl würde zu betrug führen
der kurznachrichtendienst belegte den
präsidenten suite mit einem warnhinweis
falsche fakten anprangern das will jetzt
auch facebook nach sehr langem zögern
und erst nachdem sich immer mehr
zahlungskräftige firmen distanziert
haben
facebook reagiert leider immer erst wenn
das unternehmen mit dem rücken zur wand
steht das sehen wir auch in diesem fall
große werbekunden haben damit gedroht
zukünftig nicht mehr bei facebook zu
werben wenn facebook dieses problem
nicht im griff bekommt und das heute
unsere wundern geben dass wir als die
nutzer nicht so einen großen druck haben
wirtschaftlicher druck also hat offenbar
zur facebook kehrtwende geführt die
große frage jetzt inwieweit die
verschärften regeln auch tatsächlich
umgesetzt werden um hass und lücken im
netz stärker zu bekämpfen
weitere entwicklungen im machtkampf
zwischen werbekunden politik und den
daten riesen facebook twitter und co
finden sie wie immer online auf heute de
und in unserer zdf heute morgen wählt
polen einen neuen präsidenten und viele
menschen haben die hoffnung auf einen
richtungswechsel
als favorit gilt der konservative
amtsinhaber andré duda er gilt als
gefolgsmann der regierenden
rechtskonservativen partei
aussichtsreichster herausforderer ist
der warschauer oberbürgermeister
raschkowski beobachter erwarten ein
knappes rennen natalie steger aus
warschau polens staatspräsident hat im
wahlkampf scharf polarisiert für ein
stramm nationalkonservative school
duda setzt auf sozialleistungen für die
traditionelle familie und äußert sich
abfällig über homosexuelle und
transgender sie versuchen uns zu
überzeugen dass das menschen sind aber
es ist einfach nur eine ideologie vor
allem im ländlichen polen kommt das an
duda ist der kandidat der
regierungspartei peas hat in den letzten
fünf jahren mit seiner unterschrift
umstrittene gesetze zu medien und
justizreform durchgewinkt genau das will
der aussichtsreichste
oppositionskandidat für die stichwahl in
zwei wochen keinesfalls der warschauer
bürgermeister von der
liberalkonservativen bürgerplattform er
steht ein für homo rechte und toleranz
[Applaus]
polen braucht einen starken präsidenten
der der regierung auf die finger schaut
die ein gegengewicht ist noch im mai sah
es nach einem durchmarsch von präsident
lula aus dann wurde die wahl wegen
corona verschoben die größte
oppositionspartei nutzte die chance und
tauschte ihre bis dahin blasse
kandidatin moskowski holte auf es ist
eine richtungswahl für polen zwar dürfte
da laut umfragen die erste runde
gewinnen muss aber sehr wahrscheinlich
in die stichwahl
und da könnten sich andere
oppositionskandidaten hinter den
warschauer bürgermeister stellen und es
eng werden für dudar
in sachen corona hatten die menschen in
israel eigentlich gedacht sie hätten das
schlimmste hinter sich schnell und
entschieden hatten die behörden zu
beginn der pandemie reagiert bis hin zur
handy überwachung durch den geheimdienst
und doch seit drei wochen steigen die
infektionszahlen wieder deutlich nicola
albrecht aus tel aviv die korona
stationen in israels krankenhäusern
werden wieder aufgemacht und sie fühlen
sich denn sie ist voll da die zweite
welle
doch außerhalb ist davon wenig zu merken
es ist wochenende und in den
küstenstädten feiert man sich das wetter
und das leben
es tut mir zwar leid wenn leute an
corinna sterben aber deswegen muss ja
nicht wieder das ganze land unter
lockdown gestellt werden
eigentlich hatte israel zu den ländern
gehört die als vorbilder im kampf gegen
korona galten die regierung hatte zu
beginn der pandemie strikte maßnahmen
ergriffen grenzen dicht wochenlange
ausgangssperren strenge überwachung und
drakonische strafen bei verletzung der
regeln hatten sich im april von knapp
neun millionen einwohnern bis zu 800
menschen pro tag angesteckt dachte man
im mai israel sei bald virus frei doch
nun liegt der wert wieder bei bis zu
knapp 700 neuinfektionen tendenz
steigend israels premier netanjahu ließ
weitreichende lockerungen zu weil der
druck aus der wirtschaft zu groß wurde
auch die schulen durften öffnen doch
nicht nur die erwiesen sich als
infektionsherde und mussten vielerorts
wieder geschlossen werden
das gesundheitsministerium rät aktuell
zum erneuten lockdown doch netanjahu
setzt stattdessen auf überwachung und
rät masken zu tragen und die leute die
sich nicht an die regeln halten und die
die sich angesteckt haben werden wir so
schnell wie möglich lokalisieren übermut
der geheimdienst soll nun wieder
patienten überwachen das masken tragen
ist auch draußen pflicht doch die
polizei schaut nicht überall genau hin
strikt bleibt man nur dass die grenzen
betrifft denn die bleiben bis auf
weiteres nicht viel wind und
sonnenschein haben die produktion von
ökostrom auf einen halbjahres rekord
getrieben
nach angaben des energiekonzerns e.on
sind von januar bis juni rund 126
milliarden kilowattstunden grüner strom
ins netz eingespeist worden
das sind sieben prozent mehr als im
vorjahreszeitraum
die menge an ökostrom reiche rechnerisch
aus um den strom sämtliche haushalte in
deutschland und den niederlanden für das
ganze jahr zu decken
die deutschen und die ferien das thema
dieser tage zu beginn und auch gegen
ende dieser sendung nie waren die
deutschen so ratlos was ihren
sommerurlaub angeht corona die
reisegewohnheiten radikal
durcheinandergewirbelt auf der gewinn
seite ganz klar die campingbranche
millionen sind mit dem wohnmobil dem
wohnwagen oder dem zelt unterwegs über
den camping boom jana becker philipp und
kim nina hat es zum campingurlaub nach
meerbusch bei düsseldorf verschlagen
sie haben sich vor zwei monaten einen
eigenen wohnwagen zugelegt nachdem in
mexiko urlaub storniert wurde und so
haben wir uns dann gedacht camping ist
wieder unser und haben uns dann
kurzfristig dazu entschlossen hier weiß
man wer dann das bett halt genutzt hat
vorher und das verspricht zumindest eine
gewisse sicherheit wirklich sagen auch
vielen anderen geht es darum in corona
zeiten sicher zu reisen in den
sanitäranlagen muss man ein bisschen
vorsichtiger sein dass ich nicht so
viele leute auf einmal da reingehen aber
ansonsten hat man meine eigene parzelle
hat auch genug platz für die meisten
urlauber reisen nicht mit zelten sondern
im wohnwagen oder wohnmobil an
campingplatzbetreiber rainer breitbach
profitiert von der korona krise die 300
stellplätze sind aktuell fast
vollständig belegt die leute wollten
raus wollten einen die frische luft
wollten in die natur und das haben wir
wirklich verstärkt zu spüren bekommt ein
großteil wohnt selbst in nrw und musste
nicht weit fahren auch bundesweit setzen
die deutschen auf camping urlaub im
eigenen land im vergangenen jahr lag die
zahl der übernachtungen bei 31 millionen
die korona krise verstärkt diesen trend
allein in den letzten sechs wochen
hatten wir ein wachstum von fast 300
prozent bei den nachfragen nach
deutschen campingplätzen kim nina und
philipp haben noch einen stellplatz im
eigenen bundesland ergattern können und
freuen sich über ihren ferien staat und
unsere die an ort und zum ende des
abstiegs krimi es im deutschen fußball
da schießen die bremer in vier
heimspielen hintereinander kein einziges
tor
und heute gleich ein sechserpack klarer
sieg gegen köln konkurrent düsseldorf
verliert und steigt ab werde auf dem
relegationsplatz das weser wunder
perfekt
die sonst so kühlen hanseaten außer rand
und band
vorläufige rettung auf den
relegationsplatz und tränen mehr nach
dem kantersieg gegen den ersten fc köln
kleine stroh hat er noch ausgekostet und
den haben wir eine griffen sechs tore
von werder im weserstadion das gab es
die ganze saison noch nicht die fans vor
dem stadion skandierten hier haben es
geschafft doch so weit ist es noch lange
nicht
nun kann der dino der bundesliga der
zuletzt 2004 das double holte jedoch
wenigstens hoffen eine weitere runde in
der bundesliga zu drehen
wunschgegner der werder-fans für die
relegation lokal rivale hsv jetzt sind
nicht nur die beiden direkten absteiger
klar sondern auch der vierte champions
league teilnehmer bayern dortmund
leipzig und gladbach hier alle
ergebnisse des letzten spieltags bremen
gegen köln 621 union berlin gegen
düsseldorf 13 0 dortmund hoffenheim 04
leverkusen 1 1 0 gladbach hertha 2 1
wolfsburg bayern 0 zuviel frankfurt
paderborn 3 zu 2 freiburg schalke 14 08
burg leipzig 1 zu 2 die tabelle meister
bayern dann dortmund leipzig von
gladbach danach leverkusen und
hoffenheim die sind direkt in die
champions league eingezogen wolfsburg
als siebter kann sich dafür noch
qualifizieren
am tabellenende abgestiegen paderborn
und düsseldorf bremen als sechzehnter in
der relegation gegen den dritten der
zweiten liga
alle spiele alle tore wie immer bei uns
im aktuellen sportstudio um 23 uhr
gesprächsgast von jochen breyer unter
anderem frank baumann von werder bremen
etwa 1000 schalker anhänger haben heute
vor der veltins-arena gegen s04
aufsichtsratschef clemens tönnies und
den vorstand des vereins protestiert die
demo unter dem motto schalke ist kein
schlachthof gegen die zerlegung unseres
vereins richtete sich aber auch gegen
die schlechte behandlung von
werksarbeiter im fleisch unternehmen vom
tisch
zur basketball bundesliga hat berlin im
final hinspiel um die deutsche
meisterschaft gegen ludwigsburg klar mit
88 zu 65 gewonnen
die berliner wurden ihrer favoritenrolle
von beginn an gerecht hatten bei
halbzeit bereits 17 punkte vorsprung
ja und am ende waren es dann sogar 23
punkte also beste voraussetzung für das
rückspiel morgen lang genauso gerne zum
schluss schauen wir noch in einen
außergewöhnlichen nachthimmel
in madrid wurde mit einer drohnen
lichtershow an die opfer der korona
pandemie in spanien erinnert am dunklen
himmel feierten 40 drohnen schriftzüge
wie hoffnung
außerdem die fahnen mehrerer länder und
eine taube mit der speziellen
choreografie wollten sich die
veranstalter auch bei pflegekräften und
ärzten bedanken
ein kreativer dank zum wetter da warnt
der deutsche wetterdienst aktuell vor
heftigen gewittern in niedersachsen
mecklenburg vorpommern und bayern
ob auch morgen noch gewitter drohen sagt
uns gleich katja honnef das war's für
diesen samstag schön dass sie dabei
waren
christian sievers ist wie immer am
samstag etwas später dran um drei
viertel 11 und wir sind morgen abend
wieder hier um 7 machen sie es gut
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren tief
silvia schickt uns morgen seine
kaltfront und die räumt dann auf mit der
schwülen hitze mitteleuropa und
vertreibt die auch aus ostdeutschland
und zwar mit kräftigen schauern und
gewittern aber kräftige schauer und
gewitter gab es ja auch heute schon das
ging am vormittag bereits in den
mittelgebirgen los später dann auch in
bayern und in baden württemberg auch
zwischen hamburg bremen und schleswig
holstein gab es kräftige gewitter es war
also vor allen dingen der westen und der
süden deutschlands betroffen und das
bleibt jetzt auch am abend noch so in
der nacht lassen die gewitter aber mehr
und mehr nach die nacht wird lang
die temperaturen sinken häufig nicht
unter 9 10 bis 15 grad und einzig an den
alpen wird es mit 12 grad kühler
diese kaltfront macht sich morgens schon
in westdeutschland bemerkbar da klettern
die temperaturen auf angenehme 18 bis 24
grad während es im osten noch einmal
schwül heiße 25 bis 31 grad gibt
deswegen sind dort morgen auch die
schauer und gewitter am heftigsten
das können wieder unwetter seien und an
den alpen gehen die dann zum teil gleich
in dauerregen der montag bringt
regenschauer und gewitter im süden der
dienstag regen und wind an der küste und
mittwoch die wärme schönen abend noch